Everyone has a story.
You're gonna fall right out of your seat.
But some stories are so incredible,
they deserve to be immortalized
on television.
What genre would you call this story?
Horror mystery.
Action.
Inspirational.
Join Ed Helms and Randall Park.
Where and when does this story begin?
In Nebraska.
Alexandria, Virginia.
As they hear ordinary people...
Hi!
How's it going, y'all?
...tell extraordinary true stories.
They made a typo, obviously.
And I just said, "****ing count me in."
Woah! Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
Hold on, I thought you were a
Dungeons and Dragons guy.
I'm telling you.
Then, bring them to life
with a star-studded cast.
Pretty incredible, huh?
My parents were extremely strict.
Hey yo! Have fun tonight Ronald.
What? Fun? At this hour?
-Have fun.
-You're like, "Be cool!"
-I never liked him.
-Bad influence.
Yeah, he's not even saved.
Ha ha!
What if you guys tried being me for a day?
They’re like, “Oh, like real smart and weird?”
No, I was thinking more so...
I am blown away.
You are an incredible person.
What do you think about going down
and getting the football?
And he says one of the dumbest
things I've ever heard.
Your immediate response is,
"That's a great idea."
I see this beautiful girl.
She was just glowing.
I kept looking at her, a little bit too much.
-It was awkward.
-You mean like this?
Ha ha!
Remember that.
Who the frig are you?
I would punch you in your stupid face,
but I don't wanna get grease
on my new championship ring.
Stories so amazing...
It wasn't an allergic reaction. They're very poisonous.
So dramatic.
Is he gonna propose to me?
So ridiculous...
Literal projectile vomit.
So unbelievable, they could only be true.
You snuck in the Super Bowl!
All the way to the bus,
bus guy opens the door,
Bradshaw's right in front of me.
You guys are badass!
That was the best game I've ever seen!
Wait, who was that?
I think that was the coach's nephew. Maybe.
And that’s the end of my story.
That’s my story, brothers.
That's the story guys.
-Yes! You did it!
-Yes!